la approves
unprecedented plan to take over
chinatown apartment building against
owners wishes this is a coindesk story
okay let me say this one more time lau
approves unprecedented plan to take over
a chinatown apartment building against
the owner's wishes okay l.a city council
voted friday to start the process of
acquiring an apartment building in
chinatown where low-income tenants have
faced large rent increases renters and
tenants advocates praised the vote
saying their years of organizing have
led to a significant step towards
preserving affordable rent in their
building for decades the tenants paid
rents that were capped to reflect their
low income but the 30-year agreement to
keep rents low expired a few years ago
allowing the owner to raise rent to
market rates
tenants in the building say rents have
since increased by as much as 300
percent the city's ultimate goal is to
reinstate the building's affordability
covenant for another 55 years let me
explain to you what just happened here
so this guy made a mistake what's the
mistake the mistake is 30 years ago he
went in bed with the government
and he said look this is great you guys
going to bring all the people here
you're going to pay the rent for me so
section 8 all this up freaking awesome
let's do it he signed 30 years knowing
he's going to be fully decked out
because they have to pay the rent to him
30 years later this this building that
he owns
is now worth 57 million dollars and you
know what the government's forcing to
buy it for 46 million dollars he's
losing 11 million dollars so now
somebody may say oh
cry me a river that's not the point the
government is forcing him to do
something he does not want to do
he's being cornered and forced by the
way if he decides to increase rent by
300 percent what do tenants have the
choice to do move leave to a different
place okay
and he can go from having 50 100 percent
of place rented down to what 30 20 he'll
pay the price if he increases the rent
right
in 2007 2008 obamacare was being
introduced it was kind of coming out
2009 whatever the year was was kind of
coming out
and i used to sell health insurance in
the early 2000s the moment obamacare
came out everybody called and said hey
pat oh my gosh let me tell you man we're
blowing it up i'm just i'm selling
affordable camera left and right i'm
just like 50 policies 80 policies 60
why are you not getting into obamacare
why are you not getting into this
business it's like selling like hot
cakes people are just coming because
they have to buy i said i just i don't
sell
products that is you know by the
government because there is no
complaints there's nobody i can call to
improve
they don't care about online reputation
they don't care about anything anyone
says about them what's the 1-800
customer service call for the government
it does not exist
nothing it doesn't exist so yeah what
this guy learned is it was good for 30
years but the government finally said
listen
this is ours now so if this is happening
in california
and other people get excited about this
oh my gosh imagine this becoming a
business model for the government so
if you're in a situation that's tight in
your real estate and you're thinking
about teaming up with these guys you may
want to think twice
the reason that i think you wanted to
cover this story because it it it
essentially highlights
what you stand for
you got choice or you got force
and you're all about choice options hey
you don't like it you can move great but
when the government forces you to do
something obviously you're familiar with
this you don't like that so much of
course
yeah they don't improve any i mean it's
very rare when you see the government
get involved and something gets better
the quality gets better the price gets i
mean what happens actually even if the
price gets better like you talk about
insurance everyone said oh the costs are
going to go down and i kept saying what
about the quality of care does nobody
care about that is anybody looking at
the other healthcare systems where your
prices went down and there are lines out
the door and those people are fighting
like hell to get the united states to
come and get their care so every time
the government gets involved i guarantee
you with that building with any building
they get involved you're going to see
they're going to see a catastrophe
emerge and you're right who do you
complain to when you have the owner of a
building and you have a problem you pick
up the phone you call you have a contact
you have a person that you can
they're not going to be there for you to
answer questions zero deal there's a no
win in that and there's a big headache
yeah that's the common statement when
you complain to somebody that's owned by
working with the government deal
yeah great that's right what do they say
that you get um
you've got three options you can only
pick two quality price or time right
like how long it takes to make something
so you can only pick so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here